we want to talk more about this new
coronavirus variant and the vaccine
rollout with dr
ashish jah the dean of brown university
school of public health dr
jia thank you so much for joining us
first we want to get to this new
evidence there is no new evidence rather
that this new strain is more severe so
what more do we know at this point
yeah good morning thank you for having
me on you know what we know right now
is that it does look like this strain is
more contagious
that means if you're exposed to it
you're more likely to get infected
than other strains and i agree with dr
gottlieb from the last report that
it probably is already in the u.s but
there's nothing that tells us that it's
any more severe
and that is good news and so at least we
can feel reassured about that so
far based on what we know so to that
point about it already being in the u.s
do you agree with new york governor
andrew cuomo he's among
a few people who are calling for a
ban on travel from the uk do you think
that that makes a difference right now
would that help yeah so what we know
about travel bans is it can
slow spread by a couple of weeks so it
might give us a little bit more time to
prepare
i like what governor cuomo is doing on
uh asking airlines to test people before
they get on the plane
that feels pretty reasonable i don't
think a travel ban will keep that strain
out of the u.s but it certainly might
slow things down by a little bit
and with us seeing these new changes and
these new variants with this um
this type of infection do you think that
we're going to have to modify
the vaccines as it changes
you know so these kinds of variations do
happen and whether we're going to end up
needing let's say
a year or two down the road to change
our vaccines we don't know right now
it is possible i think we should be
ready for that that a bit down the road
that might happen but i'm not worried
that the current vaccines we have
will somehow become ineffective against
this variant that seems much less likely
to me
christmas travel is already outpacing
thanksgiving
we know that we're telling people try
not to travel
but people are getting on planes trains
driving to see grandma if you will
what is your concern and again best
advice if you are going to travel
yeah you know i totally get it right we
always get together during the holidays
with our family we're not doing it this
year
my advice is if you can avoid it please
do if you can't keep it small
try to wear masks especially around
vulnerable people stay safe because
vaccines are so
close we want to make sure everybody's
safe through the holidays
so they can get vaccinated and get back
to normal next year all right dr ashish
always
great to see you thank you thank you